I am Jack Nugent, you are watching Now You See it
Let's talk about how the villain agent really laughs at you.
Quentin Tarantino is one of the most popular and violent directors
His films focus on the violence that people commit.
A group of criminals killed the hired killer
a black market munition smuggler killing
A former killer who kills for revenge
A special force targeting the Nazis during World War II
And more hired killers
Finally, his latest work "The Eight Evils" will be released in the fall of 2015.
Will be played by Hawthorn Jackson as the hired killer you guessed.
Undoubtedly Quentin Tarantino's movie
Especially his relatively high shooting budget
Brought a lot of super crazy deaths
The magazine "Floating World" has done a great chart.
Count how many people died in Quentin’s movie
Shows how violent Quentin’s movies are.
His eighth film, The Villain, is no exception.
The whole film killed 57 people.
Does not include the 342 people who died in the fire and fear.
On average, every two and a half minutes, one person will die.
Really have enough bad guys
Even the movie is so violent
The villain agent still gains commercial success
And created a box office of more than 300 million US dollars
Also won eight Oscar nominations
Most Quentin movies have excellent box office results.
In fact, in the nine films directed by Quentin
Eight have earned three times more than the budget.
So how do we explain the audience we bought to watch his movie?
Do we like violence?
Are we right to watch people who die in the movies?
Quentin knows that while presenting a violent image
It is also unlikely to criticize those who seek violent images.
So he chooses entertainment
Let's take a look at "The villain"
And see how Quentin criticizes those who admire violence.
"The Evil Agent" tells a unit named the villain agent during World War II.
Their mission is to blow up a screening of the German propaganda film.
And there are a number of Nazi officers attending the cinema.
Including Hitler himself
This promo is about a Nazi soldier named Frederick Zoller.
He killed 215 Russian soldiers in the clock tower alone.
The title of this film is regarded as "the glory of the country" is extremely violent
We can see that
In the film, there are many pictures of Frederick Zoller shooting Russian soldiers.
Nazi members are quite fond of
They laughed and admired these death pictures.
Hitler even praised the film director
This is your best movie so far.
We can’t help but watch these audiences appreciate the glory of the country.
And I feel a little ridiculous and absurd
They watched these repeated, monotonous and unnecessary kills
And think that this movie is simply a god
For us, this is just a movie with a rough scene.
But please think carefully
Don't you think it sounds familiar?
These Nazi members are watching promotional movies.
Just like we are watching this movie
This is a movie in a movie.
When we see the reaction of Quentin's super shot
Isn't that the same?
I want to say that Quentin is going to express
When we are watching "The villain"
It’s no different from Nazi party members watching the Glory of the Country.
We will cheer
Even if it is a boring, over-beautified and unnecessary violent death shot
We saw too many violent shots in The Villain
Even the Nazis who watched the Glory of the Country
Deep in the plan to blow up the cinema
Even the cinema owner is in another wave of plans
I plan to burn a whole cinema and seal all the exits.
Let the Nazi party members get trapped and burned
Even the task of killing all Nazi members has been successful.
They are still shooting at the Nazi party members.
More unnecessary violence
Then blow up the entire movie theater
Then more unnecessary violence shots
The whole film is full of absurd violence
People cut off the scalp
Smash with a bat to death
There is also a gun to beat the eggs.
In The Glory of the Country and The Agent of the Villain
There are too many violent shots
Similarities are more than these
The protagonists of both films use the knife to engrave the Nazi symbols.
And they are very loyal to their country.
There are even a few shots that are very similar in both pieces.
Take a look at the shot of this person flying from the explosion of the cinema.
And this shot is in the "Glory of the Country"
Quentin wants to express his own film and is not far from the glory of the country.
Even the title can be compared
"Shameless bastard" and "the glory of the country" are completely opposite meanings.
This film is so similar to the audience.
We watched "The Villain"
Nazi party members watch "The Glory of the Country"
We all appreciate the violence in the film.
We all cheer for death
We are all guilty of brutal killings.
Through our comparison with Nazi members
Quentin criticizes the excessive violence we love
We are a group of cold-blooded feelings of brutality
And the ignorant viewers who can also find fun
Similarly, Nazi members are also portrayed as simple minds.
Can also find fun from the brutal "Glory of the Country"
Quentin is teasing us
The story he said is as ridiculous as the Nazi party members saw.
Look at other violent shots
Even his villain agents are doing everything they need.
Quentin did the same thing in all his movies.
He sometimes uses death to make comedy effects.
He let the audience enter a world where death will become a wonderful point.
But there are more meanings
The distance across the screen makes us feel less irritating
When we watch a movie, we can tell that this is different from real death.
Quentin knows that this distance of death will be funny.
"The Glory of the Country" is a parable that tells us how ridiculous this is.
Do we praise the violence in the film and criticize the reality is not hypocritical?
There is another interesting story about these two films and their respective audiences.
When the Glory of the Country is being shown
Susanna shot the real Frederick
But no Nazi audience found
Because they are addicted to the violence in the movie
They thought that the gunshots were the sound effects of the movie.
Does Quentin comment on us?
Explain how we don't express our opinions or care about the real world.
And only focus on the movies we love.
"The villain" is not the only movie that criticizes the audience.
Any movie shown to the audience
It’s possible that the director is trying to criticize the audience of the movie.
"Wolf of Wall Street" tells a corrupt businessman named Jordan Belfort
Ups and downs
He is unfaithful to his wife
Stealing thousands of people’s money
Later I understood the people who really love him.
And stayed in prison for a few years
Theoretically speaking
We should think that Jordan Belfort is a dishonest and despicable man.
But look at the expressions of the audience in the final scene.
Do they seem to despise him?
They worship him and want to be like him
Fame and fortune, no matter how much dishonesty and thieves
Just like "The villain agent"
The director let us see the defects of the audience.
Is Jordan Belfort really the kind of person we should strive to be?
Smart directors can use the audience or the crowd to summarize the whole society.
After all, this is the most interesting place.
When the arguments are centered around the audience watching the movie
Who is far from perfect?
So when you see another movie next time
Ask yourself if they are laughing at me?